oil Venezuela's greatest natural
resource but also its greatest curse oil
kept medoras predecessor who go Chavez
afloat for a decade before the price
fell dramatically in 2008 after Chavez
is death in 2013 Nicolas Maduro became
president he continued the Chavez
government's economic policies but oil
prices fell dramatically again in 2014
for years the low price of oil has put a
strain on the Venezuelan economy to help
it recover Maduro introduced the petro
in February 2018 a cryptocurrency pegged
to the price of oil but in September
2018 the petrol tank - in August 2018
Maduro announced a 3000 percent hike in
the minimum wage to quell unrest over
inflation and shortages but by December
last year inflation hit a whopping 1.7
million percent the Bloomberg News
Agency came up with the Cafe con Leche
index the price of a cup of coffee
reached 2 million bolivars in June of
2018 at the time around 50 US cents
Maduro revalued the national currency
the bolivar slashing five zeros that
brought the cost of a cup of coffee down
to 20 bolivars but by the start of 2019
the price again soared to 1.4 million of
the new bolivars that's equal to 140
million old bolivars people run to buy
groceries as soon as they get paid
before their salary loses its value
that's if they can even find food
Venezuelans are tired of shortages and
inflation more than three million of
them have left the country in recent
years fleeing mainly to Colombia but the
anger is growing among those who have
stayed
you
you